and welcome to this special edition of
Hannity liberal lawlessness now tonight
for the hour we're going to show you
what happens when Democrats rule over
cities and states for decades and the
Damage that they are doing in D.C it is
being felt by every single American and
they have literally taken a wrecking
ball to the entire economy China is on
the March and you're President Joe Biden
he's building sand castles and sitting
on a beach in Delaware but first there
is a reason that Americans are fleeing
New York New Jersey California Illinois
these liberal states and there's a
reason two million Americans left
America's big cities just in the last
two years High income taxes High
property taxes High sales taxes punitive
regulations and for what the roads are
covered with potholes the streets are
littered with tons of trash the homeless
crisis that's worse than ever and the
Public School Systems they're a disaster
and by the way for example look at
Baltimore 23 Baltimore more City Schools
zero students not one is proficient in
math 23 schools not a single student now
that's what 1.6 billion dollars or 20
grand per student bought the taxpayers
of Baltimore and forget about Public
Safety take a look at your screen here's
what Public Safety looks like in Chicago
mob beatings in broad daylight last
weekend hordes of teens taking over the
streets smashing cars assaulting
pedestrians and breaking windows in a
statement Chicago's radical incoming
mayor responded quote it is not
constructive to demonize youth who have
otherwise been starved of opportunities
in their own communities what okay now
of course the murder crisis in Chicago
that's even worse now fake news CNN they
would have you believe that guns kind of
magically walk down the street and act
on their own and commit these acts of
violence all by themselves they almost
never attach a human being to the
violent criminals who are actually
committing these crimes and that's
because these violent offenders they're
walking the streets thanks to democratic
policies and Democratic DA's where
killers they get a free pass in fact the
majority of murders in Chicago do not
result in charges meanwhile here's
what's happening out in California the
golden state is now being wrecked by
looters take a look there that's a local
gas station in Compton California but
the problem is Statewide and Nationwide
and in many blue areas for example the
Whole Food store in San Francisco
they're closing down why because of the
horrible conditions in the city and of
course New York City is also suffering
from a crime wave robbery grand larceny
is way up after Manhattan DEA Alvin
Bragg vowed not to prosecute theft to
establish quote racial equity in other
words if you're a criminal you can steal
whatever you want don't go to jail and
meanwhile felony assault is up 15
percent here there's a police officer
getting attacked in broad daylight on
Monday for no reason at all whatsoever
and look at this new video also from New
York where a driver is plowing through
an outdoor dining space striking police
officers during a Pursuit now naturally
AOC had to weigh in she's very angry
what is she angry at the police take a
look you're talking about funding
violence prevention outside of the
police and yet Eric Adams has just
increased police wages by 28 percent is
that misplaced I I think so we are
defunding safety defunding our Public
Schools defunding our public pools
defunding our Parks defunding our
libraries when we are taking all of
those resources and demanding that every
single Department except the militarized
one because we are sending a message
about who and what we care about
now one New York City attack victim who
lost an eye because of a random beating
at the hands of a Maniac on a subway
platform just responded to AOC and here
is what she had to say take a look at
this
I believe safety come with police
officers and once there's police
officers then people feel more related
to go places they wouldn't feel scared
to go to school they wouldn't be scared
to go to a public pool we wouldn't be
scared to be on the train station just
going to work you know there's times and
place for everything and once you put
Safety First everything else will go
right after it I cannot call a teacher
if I need help if a man is running me
down I cannot call a teacher I'm gonna
have to call the police I'm going to be
praying for a police not a teacher
oh there is no doubt that police play a
critical role in public safety but
Democrats they don't care for them
political messaging virtue signaling
that's way more important and now the
less defund dismantle and no bail laws
they are destroying major cities they're
not protecting the innocent it is
impacting the entire country so it's not
a mystery why Americans are now fleeing
blue States and blue cities you have
law-abiding hard-working taxpayers
they're getting fleeced by democrats
spending their hard-earned tax dollars
on far-left pet projects government
handouts billions and billions of
dollars on new green deal initiatives
and of course massive payouts to public
sector unions who collude with Democrats
to steal money from American workers or
you could look at New York City Second
Avenue subway for example you have three
stations and just over a mile of new
track it costs taxpayers a whopping four
point five billion dollars and took 45
years to complete if it wasn't so
pathetic it's laughable and by the way
it is now filled with human waste and a
lot of homeless people this is not a
good life for workers and their families
and now they're voting with their feet
and by the way who can blame them hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else